non bernieri potuto aiutare il gabinetto
del resto la nostra sinistra c'è
qualcuno dietro di lui scappa c'è stato
abbastanza oggi non vi siano equi primi
dobbiamo scappare dallo studioso passo
che sto facendo degli esperimenti sugli
esseri umani come potete vedere qua
guardate dentro ci sono dei personaggi
poverini loro sono i malcapitati su cui
sta facendo prive di marchio lebole
vendita un altro binario
cosa ci è successo abbiamo un faccione
quadrato eccoci qua sembriamo dei
personaggi di minecraft tu dove sei qui
siamo uguali perché siamo gridi continuo
rap lo so questo escluso di youtubers o
non credo che dobbiamo andare vi per
iniziare allora modalità normale si è
meglio di stare con la modalità normale
perché è dai ma non è meno facile se la
vota vita facile
la tesi solo d'accordo ma forse poi
possiamo prendere dei vestiti o andiamo
quasi completamente bianchi dei vestiti
e qui ho visto qualcosa delle tutine al
neon neo non vediamo storico
vabbè vorrei dire che rimarremo così dei
quadratini via minecraft e non ci
abbiamo il sorriso regia ok siamo nella
modalità facile basta dove tutto il
mondo arredo che porta invece ha scritto
qui e mi sa che quando c'è scritto dai
pronto fra
dovevo dire portale mi raccomando voi se
non vi siete ancora letti comodi
mettetevi comodi possono mangiare
soprattutto
eccoci tv dormendo siamo in una stanza
con la scritta m perché i capelli grigi
e seta invecchiava l'altro al tempo
con presentiamo nell'altra
e questo alla tua sinistra ma è lui il
dottore perché mi guarda così
inquietante forse uno dei suoi
esperimenti così male si no ho lavorato
si è chiuso con l'età anche per rifare
gli esperimenti deve uscire da questo
posto a trovare una cura
proviamo a scappare da dove sei facciamo
quindi 33 eccovi il trancio
siamo tornati 2 quadratini e siamo
riusciti a scappare dalla ma possiamo
orientata dentro tipo
non lo so che è successo ho trovato la
porta pvm in kate che si chiama dentro
pure ha chiuso quando entro quest'anno
catturato partita l'altro potevo
liberarlo poverino cosa c'è ho scoperto
una scala forza qualsiasi
il mio era solo un amore
guarderò sempre passiamo sopra un altro
pianeta si su un altro tema che si su un
altro pianeta
finora sembra tutto tranquillo finché il
dottor grimm non si accorgerà che siamo
scappati qui dobbiamo saltare su queste
piattaforme blu
proviamo attenzione non mi sono fatto
aggiornato
italia
[Musica]
se tu come
ho capito cosa devo fare doppio salto
aiuto c'è qualcuno fino a preparato come
chi sei c'è qualcuno che mi stava
inseguendo non lo so chi è e ti formati
non credo che sia una spina
dell'eduzione
rifare daccapo questa parte mentre
pilota che vincerà questa sfida
riuscirò io finire per primo sicuramente
sei riuscito a oltrepassare il robottino
ha voglia st tantissimo tipo sono
arrivato tipo nella sezione oceano
e aspetta un momento
bar si ricomincia da capo come da capo
ad un numero che doveri prima vero super
avanti ok allora da questa parte in poi
stai attenta perché super difficile un
doppio salto ma noi non è riuscito a
passare normalmente senza ma senza che a
crearsi qui siamo in via dei soldi che
aveva doppio palo
no io avevo raramente
sembra che scompaia la griglia in questo
che volevo avvisare di questo non sono
riuscito a dire però è caduto hecker
superato ad oggi
ci sono i laser i preferiti di vitale no
come fatto ad arrivare i laser non c ero
ancora arrivato sesto giro emilio
cellino preso da solo tipo degli
ingranaggi ma continua ci
sono tantissimi ho bisogno di trovare un
modo per disabilitare qui è solo questo
errore ho premuto è scoppiato qualcosa
di militari la sentirei tutto è sparito
si devi premere il bottone e poi passi
da qui
allora dice pericolo alto voltaggio non
aprire
tra questi sicuro che possiamo aprirlo e
ora si è aperta forse che si sono
gettati ma ci sono delle grandi voci
però perché sia spenta la luce o no sta
succedendo qualcosa si è diventato tutto
più paura le
citochine robottini volanti
dobbiamo stargli in testa veniamo adesso
passare
[Musica]
ok bisogna star in testa poi saltare noi
di fede farlo super velocissimi la vetta
e super difficile
no io adesso
ce l'ha fatta
tutti altro perché mi sono confuso quasi
un baule è un ingranaggio rosso deve
essere un ingranaggio rare bisogna dare
posso chiuso qui dentro
ha forse ho capito bisogna stare sfida
questa da questo evento e
impiegati
sull'abilità o no ha detto ci sono poi
gli fai come ti chiamano fila perché ci
stanno cercando o no hope per noi camere
di sicurezza vedi
non farti vedere dalle camere di
sicurezza o eccoti dai sbrigati che cosa
sia processo verbale c'è un prigioniero
se mi fai uscire da questa cella di
torva scappare da questo perché ricordo
tutti compresso e questo non
va bene dai aiuti a volo qui c'è
qualcosa di verde con scritto sel dr
quindi dobbiamo tipo cliccare questo per
avere nella morsa della cella giusto e
penso di sì che è successo tiriamo una
leva e io sono rimasto bloccato i
diavoli sia per lavoro si è
rivelato che figo grazie però prima
parte si sta chiamando con un telefono
non lo so non mi dire che era una
trappola
ho paura di sì
no ho aperto la porta si sta facendo
uscire
vai avanti di rosi un po dopo dice
krypton
persona speciale secondo te beh
innanzitutto prendiamo quel
il villaggio ina
non per merito ma per capire
chi fosse proprio arrivato da quant'è
che non tira via
proprio attacco
allontaniamoci da cristo che sicuramente
butta no devi stare attenta perché le
griglie spariscono ogni tanto ok
velocissimamente coppa partiamo se ce
l'ha fatta vita di eroi via dai vi
aspetto qui sotto sbrighi brividi si
ok abbiamo ora che corridoio strappo c'è
cosa che cosa è successo a petit bon
robot
al servizio di dottor greene
già stato
colpito
ma perché questo personaggio non correva
camminano come primo a saltare aiuto che
rincorrendo un quarto ed immortale e
così ibrido il tuo nome laggiù dove io
non ce ne sono due io aiuto no ai propri
bile da che parte dobbiamo andare e lo
stanno alzando
dobbiamo andare qua io l'ho superato
brava di qua
l'assenza sempre 19 giro molto che prova
a passare dietro
non credo che si giri anzi no mi
sbagliavo si dirà sì ma quando e questa
luce rossa sei riuscito a trapani sono
premio
siamo riusciti a scappare nero bothma ma
siamo tornati via coro
si è
mai da questa notte sta accanto c'è
mancato poco
ma questo senso i fatti
no no no tutto
più difficile proprio
la freccia
che intero trova alla freccia ecco che
non sono qui non mi sono scoperto dai
comitati
90 diciamo da questo labirinto se fosse
una monetina tribù uscito
così siamo finiti se non strino giusto
bisogna tieni le mani lontane dalla
macchina in movimento e vale c'è un
problema tutti parlerebbero anche le
mani a stento non cadere
ma così no peccato per un ti ho visto
forse moto nel macchinario
ma come fatto a saltare con gli spuntoni
miss fragiello sempre lì devi aspettare
[Musica]
si ok io mi posso vedere lo spettacolo
da qui sopra vediamo quante volte
esistono generale dove sei
ma non ho fatto di rete cioè ero
l'immobile brava aspetta bari tra ok
prima parte superata ecco vitale la juke
mai
[Musica]
doppio salto mi senti pizzicate di dire
però trovo a prendere un po di ricorso
ma ricorda troppo
comunque incredibile in questi promesso
tracceranno il doppio delle volte
limitato
allora proviamo il bottone ascensore
e ora e allora qui ci sono super
velocità formato atx e fascinoso e dove
non era tipo da rtv una cascata e
aspetta non capisco dove devo saltare a
forse sotto bisogna inchinarsi
sono e stellato
brevissimo è un testamento
mi sono trovati a dimora inchinarmi ma
devo saltare o no
che cos'è
ma perché fai scoreggia autorità
che sta succedendo perché il mio
personaggio farneti rumori strani
pascoal reggiardo ecco perché è film
moment slater ci sono eco vita e dopo di
subire o fracella menti e super velocità
tanto potrebbe essere una trappola del
laboratorio
nuovo parkour aspettava da qui c'è un
buffo fiera sì ho trovato un settore
lei non mettono avanti
sorprende io non c'è problema no ma
abbiamo visto il laser
sì quelli rossi bisogna saltarle
days later eccoci qua io evitare una
fianco all'altro difficile distinguersi
tranne per il nome sopra e tranne da
però rebella di più
cioè tu
allora astensione perché qui c'è la
supervelocità
all'improvviso sicilia
ci sono 6 mila sono
presenti almeno ricominciato d'acqua ma
perché un padre che brava ragazza che
volete ha giocato ha fatto che prima o
poi ho superato ok ora superiamo questa
festa che c'è un altro premio
io ok capito come fare bisogna frenare
è depressa via via via dove siamo finiti
no
non ce la faccio
dove poté aspettano la cosa
non vera visto c'è un ragno tuo di
iragna seguì sento tesoro sono qui ieri
che gli editti nei primi 20 sono
fioccate è ok qui vedi le scale stati su
le parti non ho
bisogno di mandata in
effetti solida
ok allora che ci sono delle bolle di
sapone che non sempre a bolle di sapone
ma sembra di buon vulcano che stai
mettendo della nave fu marchio
non so neanch'io allora guarda le dice
c'è un incubo che gira quindi forse noi
dobbiamo salire su quel cubo che gira
credo che sia super complicato si è
molto difficile che
l'ha fatta bisogna forse bisogna
abbassare
mi sono spostato su caputo apre un po di
trovate già a parte nella storia
sbattere lei se volete entrare a far
parte vasto distinguervi al canale
attivare la campanella e se non ce
l'avete ancora
vista e ovviamente leggerlo e poi fatemi
sapere e stata la nostra storia
preferita vostra creatura preferita
cliccate nel link in descrizione per
prenderlo subito ok riproviamo perché ti
sei buttate via prima che arrivi questo
quadro ha detto fai come ho fatto io per
ora penso che adesso bisogna starci
sopra dry è però non ho timore ok sono
immobile ok ci siamo wow
[Musica]
bravissimo che hai capito che bisognava
stare hajar modestamente aiutato me e
ora il pavimento e la baa bà chakwal
quadro che non cosa qui anche quando
dovremo aspettare quella piattaforma mac
all anno l'abbiamo vista
speriamo alla fine di questo laboratorio
di rc è la sezione sta volando di
riuscire a tornare con la nostra forma
normale e non essere più dei quadratini
ce l'hai fatto abbassare sempre lì
sbriga di eccoli allora ci sono dei
laser sto tremando non lo so che già c'è
qualcuno dietro di lei scappa c'è stato
qualcosa che ha già preso
un pagliaccio voi detti appena pa.it
gigantissimi scappa a me sembra una
pulce la pulce gambe chi deve dicendo
azzecca gigante visto che aveva tutte le
staffette che si corre senza girarsi
però girando di sangue ciao a tutti gli
enti scappata 10 più robusti a pensare a
qualcos'altro
io son passato forse un demone pop sono
degli esseri mitici
rava
cisco e vinto premi un sistema dove
bisogna allargare tu hai fatto
quanto divertente
stop and
go era quella cosa
boh non lo so ma dobbiamo uscire di qui
aspetta perché siamo stati trasformati
in queste in queste
non c'è tempo per spiegare a trovare la
cura ma prima dobbiamo trattare i miei
amici benissimo ok repo rate che dopo
torniamo normali visto
carlo cappi scappato dal laboratorio
capitolo 2 pressione hanno fatto quindi
dei commenti questa vostra parte
preferiranno vi lasciamo con quattro
candeline esplicare prevedendo tre altri
video e capivo quello che preferite non
farti di schiacciare la brezza
schiacciare navigare